is the respirator a clue
new caledonia is remaining a french
territory
although voter turnout was low at around
45 percent 96 percent of islanders who
did vote rejected the latest bid for
independence
it was the third and final referendum in
the past three years voters sided with
france and all of them
this victory is beautiful it's the
beginning of something new in the french
republic and i'm proud of it
independence groups boycotted the vote
they say holding the referendum during
coveted lockdown was both unfair and led
to biased results
new caledonia is east of australia and
is strategically important to france
which has a military base there
government leaders in paris feared an
independent new caledonia would move
closer to china which has built economic
ties and political influence on other
pacific islands
new caledonians have chosen to remain
french they have freely decided to do so
for the entire nation this choice is a
source of pride and recognition this
evening france is more beautiful because
new caledonia has decided to stay part
of it
with a population of about 275 000 and a
week economy some analysts say having
the backing of france may have given
residents a sense of security which
helped
new caledonia with vaccines and as well
as all the
the social
and economic measures help to boost the
economy during
this
this health crisis
now a new stage of negotiations will
begin while the territory will remain
part of france caledonian leaders
including separatists will have up to 18
months to negotiate with the french
government and redefine a new status for
the territory
katya lopes of the young al jazeera